Good morning, Buenos Diaz. Welcome to
Better Than Food book reviews. I am your
host, Cliff Sergeant. Roberto
Balano
666. I never really understood how
somebody was supposed to say the title.
That's great. It still got me wondering.
So much mystery. This is for George
Rainoff who just suggested I review some
Bologano. Good call. When I was about 20
years old, 19 or 20 years old, this was
a book that actually got me back into
reading fiercely and uh seeking out
literature. My go-to is Bologania. I'd
read a few other hefty novels when I was
a teenager, but this was really the one
that kicked off the search for great
literature. And what a perfect gateway
drug. It's been five or six years since
I've read it, but Bologania still
remains one of my absolute favorite
authors. And there's a great story
behind this book as well. So, let's get
right to it. So
2666 was a race against time for
Bologano. He was quite literally dying
while he was writing it. And a month
before he died, he said that there were
about a thousand pages that still had to
be revised.
So what you get is what you get. So it
was essentially unfinished. Roberto de
Balano spent a lot of his life in Spain
and probably considers himself Spanish,
but he was born in Chile and was present
for the military
extravaganza started by Austo Pinish. So
in his younger years after getting
involved with some left-wing politics in
Mexico City where he was living in 1973,
he took off back to Chile to go and
support the socialist regime of Salvador
Aende. Aende was overthrown and murdered
in a coup staged by Austo Pinese, a
right-wing dictator who was then
responsible for the torture and murder
of many perceived
enemies. Balano being the dangerous
left-wing poet that he was was of course
one of these perceived enemies and was
subsequently locked up. He was arrested
on suspect of being a terrorist. Then he
was actually saved by two of his former
friends who had grown up to become
prison guards. Can't make that [__] up,
unless of course he was. So in the early
80s, Bologano took off for Europe. He
settled in Barcelona, hung out there for
a while, and then he settled on a small
town near Barcelona called Blanes,
little town on the coast of Brava, where
he would remain for the rest of his
life. Like I said before, Roberto
Bologano is the best gateway drug to any
new reader of Latin American fiction,
mostly because he doesn't abide by the
rules at all. He is certainly influenced
and admits his love for people like
Bourhees or Cortasar, but in no way is
he trapped inside magical realism or
some [__] Bologano is on his own
[__] Bologano is his own [__] and 2666
is the last nail in the coffin to prove
it. That was pretty dark. He claimed he
was a poet first and foremost, but in
the early '90s, he started to write
fiction, he claims, in order to support
his children and family. This is his
magnum opus. Literally, he was racing
against time to finish it. Five parts,
and they even found a sixth after it was
published. Five-part epic tied together
by the murders in a fictional town
called Santa Teresa, which is based
directly off of Suodarez on the border
of the US and Mexico. There have been
hundreds of murders of young girls in
Soduarez for the last, oh, I don't
know, a long time. Anybody out there
been to Wararez? Driven along the
border? It's a scary [__] place. The
world is a strange, scary, mysterious,
beautiful, violent, humorous, but
ultimately tragic place to be. And
uh especially in Bologano's
literature. So,
I think you would agree. Anyways, by the
end of the book, we eventually see how
these five stories are connected. And
this is over a thousand pages, but it's
actually pretty easy read. You shouldn't
be intimidated by it at all. It's pretty
good. The first story concerns four
literary critics who are searching for a
German writer named Benovon
Alche. Benovon Al Archbaldi. Archbaldi.
This is actually my favorite story out
of all of them. Just these uh four
obsessed literary critics who are
searching for this uh extremely
mysterious and elusive writer. And they
hear from a very unlikely source that he
is in Santa Teresa. The second story
concerns a single dad who moved with his
daughter from Barcelona to Santa Teresa
and is of course worried about her
safety and her becoming a victim to
these murders. The third story is about
a New York journalist named Oscar Fate
who was sent to Santa Teresa to cover a
boxing match. And this is something he
knows nothing about. But subsequently
while he's there, he meets another
journalist who is covering the murders.
And he begins to become very interested
in what's going on around him. And this
eventually leads to him getting an
interview with the prime suspect of
these murders who is a German man named
Klaus Hos. Which leads us into the
fourth story which is all about Klaus
Hos and him in prison and then all about
the murders. A real significant part and
the real dividing factor among readers
of this book is uh the descriptions of
the girls and the ways that they were
murdered. It's often so emotionally
removed as to seem almost like a
straight crime scene report, but then
often very subtly there will be uh an
anecdote about their personal lives or
their hopes or family or desires or
friends uh that adds kind of to the
horror of the whole scenario and it
really brings you back to it in a brutal
brutal way. Uh but it's always but it's
kind of understated, right? Juxtaposed
to these extremely almost like clinical
descriptions of violence upon, you know,
bodies. It's not easy, but it shouldn't
be. I mean, that's why I
mean, we shouldn't just gloss over the
fact that these young women are being
raped and murdered. I mean, that, you
know, you should feel something. You
should feel emotionally moved somehow.
So I'm a
uh very supportive of of the manner in
which he is he has written about these
murders. I think he has treated it very
very respectfully and uh because it is
disturbing. The whole thing is
disturbing. Real life is disturbing and
it should you know literature ought to
feel like real life or more than real
life. Finally, the fifth story concerns
the author Archin Baldi and uh we see
how all the puzzle pieces fit in and so
on and so forth, but nothing is ever
over. And Bologanio really proves that
nothing is ever over. And Bologano
passed away at the age the ripeole age
of
50 from liver disease back in 2003.
I think the first edition of 2666 came
out in Spanish, of course, uh in uh
2004. He was on the list to get a liver
transplant and he was near the top of
the list by the time he died. I remember
going to uh an exhibit at a museum, like
a retrospective of Bologano's work uh
while I was staying for a couple months
in Barcelona about two years ago, and I
remember uh they had several pairs, like
two or three pairs of his
glasses, and those were easily the most
disturbing artifacts in the entire
exhibit. I mean, they had plenty of
personal writings and then uh
typewriters, but his glasses, the things
he wore on his face every day, the
things he took off to have sex with his
wife, the things through which he saw
the computer or the piece of paper that
he was writing his novels, the things
through which he saw the world.
Basically, I don't know this I'm not
even trying to be poetic. I just think
that's very that's that's such an
intimate thing to see. And I just
remember being very very
um
um moved and uh disturbed by that. It
was it was the most effective reminder
that death is right around the corner. I
mean, who I don't think Bologanio
thought that some like tall gringo kid
in Barcelona was going to be like
staring at his glasses one day like on
the verge of tears in a museum, you
know? You don't think about [__] like
that. But I
mean,
hey, keeps life interesting, right? I
mean, if you can't tell by now, he's one
of my absolute favorites. I mean, I love
him. I love him. I loved I loved him the
first time I read this book. I still
love him. I'll read it again, you know,
and hopefully again after that. I did my
thesis film at film school based on one
of his short stories called The Return.
It's about a man who dies in a
nightclub, but unfortunately steps out
of his body Patrick sees style only to
witness his body getting stolen from the
morg and taken to a very famous fashion
designer who is a closet
necrophiliac. I made that movie and you
can watch it. It went over really well.
Link down below. I don't know if
Bologano would approve, but I think he
would be entertained. As far as my own
personal taste is concerned, I owe a lot
to Blanio and I don't think this review
covered near enough of him. So, I'll
review some more of his stuff in the
future. But for now, here's a little
taste. Start with this uh wherever the
[__] it went. Okay. Uh start with, you
know, 266 or, you know, start with uh uh
The Savage Detectives. If you can read
Spanish, read the original versions. I'm
a [__] I'm, you know, uneducated
piece of [__] So, uh I only speak
English, unfortunately. Working on that.
Hit me up with some comments and please
subscribe if you want more books. You
need more books. You need to read more.
You know it. So, always remember what
Mr. John Waters
said. You go home with somebody and they
don't have books. Oh, if they don't have
Roberto Bologano, don't [__] them. Don't
[__] talk to them. Don't touch. If
they've never heard of Bologano, just
run away. Run other direction. Run.
There's plenty more wonderful fish in
the sea out there who have read or heard
of Bologano at least. Plenty, plenty,
plenty. So, in true Savage Detective
fashion, I'm going on a road trip down
the 101 to Los Angeles. So, you're going
to have to excuse me for about five or 6
days while I
um get the [__]
out. Okay, cool. Thanks. You should get
out, too. Yeah, you need a break. Yeah,
you do. Okay. All right. Thanks again,
George. See you guys later. Have a great
day.